gentrification doesn't happen because
people build new buildings
gentrification happens people don't this
is a video about housing that way but do
relates to a lot of cities in North
America it's about the cost of buying a
house I basically want to know if me or
my friends anyone in the middle class
we'd ever be able to afford a house in a
city again but this whole thing it
actually started out with a much simpler
idea for LA teachers reactance I mean no
do you think it's common sense that
teachers should be able to afford houses
in the communities where they teach so I
brought in all these teachers and I had
them look at how much house they could
afford using these basic online
calculators okay so it says I can afford
a two hundred fifty seven thousand
dollar house with a mortgage payment of
thirteen hundred and one dollars Wow
okay well I could purchase land but not
a house so it's basically like in the
armpit of two freeways yeah it's a
1-bedroom 1-bath oh the bedroom is part
of the living room looks like yeah okay
let's say I can afford this I'm also
gonna get cancer to about 30 feet away
from power lines so that probably
explains the slightly lower price all
that video really Illustrated was that
houses do indeed cost too much
teachers are indeed not paid enough and
it was just kind of a bummer it's kind
of depressing to see what's out there in
our price range so the real video starts
now
I talk to all these academics and they
broke it down it comes down to supply
and demand the big challenge is when
there is a vibrant economic space kind
of how do we accommodate new migrants
into that into that city and I mean the
idea is you know housing lasts for a
really long time in a hundred years for
a housing unit and you can you build
your housing stock one year at a time
you can't build too many in any one year
and
so if you have ten years in a row we
don't build much that creates a real
hole in your housing stock for the
future because there's a housing
shortage it means that upper middle
class people move into what are
traditionally working-class
neighborhoods in order to afford a home
and that ends up making it difficult for
the traditional residents of this
neighborhoods to afford a place to live
in their own community that's what we
ended up is it then you know
middle-class housing has been converted
into rich people's housing and the
working man's housing has been turned
into middle class housing and then the
poor people's housing is kind of been
erased and it's actually important to
note that the gentrification professor
Myers is describing generally means it's
communities of color that are being
displaced to see what that looks like
firsthand I met up with a supercool
real-estate agent her name's Rose Garcia
and she works in all these developing
neighborhoods and she showed me around
them and we looked at these houses that
you know five years ago would cost
$100,000 and are now going for three or
four times that this home it's like less
than a thousand a thousand square feet I
think it's like 1,100 square feet it's
for sale for 305 and the problem is that
it's a total fiction and not to mention
the nice lot size again you're up
against an alleyway so this is the last
kind of home that the standard average
you know city employee teacher anyone
that makes around sixty five thousand
sixty thousand dollars a year this is
what you're getting you're getting an
extreme super fixer-upper in an area
that's in the bud the budding of its
gentrification oh and another thing
about the services there's a wild
chihuahua packs they just run
frivolously in the street just like
attacking people it's crazy you don't
have that on the west side no they don't
well welcome Cecily I'm born and raised
in Highland Park I'm born in 74 lived in
Highland Park my whole entire life I
still live there now and you know it's
amazing to me as an agent I've been in
this business 16 years that people are
paying you know upwards near $700,000
for a house where I know people who got
in a shot at I mean it's crazy that's
part of what's happening in not only LA
but in the nation I like I said I we own
lumps there I'm happy that it's
happening it's just uh it's happening
really fast and you know a blink of an
eye I'm like what happened to my city
it's just so different and so the
question I asked is like what can we do
as a society or the city or what me just
as a dude who cares about these things
how can we make it better government
really has to allow more housing to be
built and then also to make sure that
those who have the least amount of money
can still afford housing it just takes
too long to get projects planned and get
them approved and get them built in
terms of general policy to help create
more housing in Los Angeles the number
one thing I think is like is up zone the
city and by that we mean like if you
look at any piece of land right in Los
Angeles if there's me a rules from the
zoning cuff how much units of housing
can you do there and that's the
restriction that's really keeping us
from creating enough housing in Los
Angeles so we need to really think hey
are we a city they actually wants a lot
of people to be here that wants to be
diverse that wants to build transit the
ones left people of walkable communities
and if so let's let there be a little
bit of density in a few other places
other than just downtown and like
Hollywood another obstacle of housing is
that every time you build anything in
Los Angeles you have to put in a certain
number of parking spaces whether you
need them or not
a lot of cases there are two parking
spots required per unit built kinda like
that kind of stuff drives up the cost of
construction and it makes it harder to
meet our needs for for more housing so I
met it was a guy his name's Matt Smith
and he calls himself a socialist
developer and he really EKKO he took
this old bungalow Ford and he turned
into townhomes that were kind of like
condos but were classified as
single-family homes and for some kind of
arcane reasons were much cheaper to
develop we're a developer doing socially
conscious projects in Los Angeles we
like to do things that are regulatorily
innovative and so a jane Blumenfeld the
planner in the city of Los Angeles said
why is it that everything has to be a
condo and so she worked for a couple
years to craft something called the
small lot ordinance which actually lets
you develop townhouse type buildings
like that kind of density on small lots
so using land much more efficiently and
simply by doing this it's allowed
developers like me to cut our cost to
the point where we can afford to build
at a price that more people can afford
to buy it doesn't solve the
affordability problem by any stretch of
the imagination but when we did this
project this was still the lowest priced
new quality single-family housing in the
area futures not finding a way to do
cul-de-sacs and 5,000 square foot houses
on 10,000 square foot Lots and somehow
make that affordable to the world I
don't think that's a winning strategy I
think the future is coming up with new
ways of building housing new ways of
being in the city and using all of our
resources more efficiently and that's
just one example of a rule change to see
laws that let the developer build more
for cheaper so we definitely need to
encourage the city to make it easier to
build but overall we as a generation
just need
pay a lot more attention to the health
of the housing stock in our cities
most people are just kind of in it for
themselves as long as they can afford to
buy a house or rent a house the overall
housing stock doesn't matter fit but the
truth is if you actually want to live in
a city that is a cool diverse
interesting place this is like one of
the main things that you should pay
attention to in like the politics of
your city and that's why I made this
video
[Music]